WARREN POWELL: The OJ game is
a particular exercise where
they form teams of five or six
students to run an orange
juice products enterprise.
This is where they have
to decide how to buy
orange juice futures.
They do contracts.
They do shipping.
They have to locate
manufacturing and storage
facilities.
They have to try to understand
the market.
They have to learn how people
respond to prices.
We do simulate things like
outages due to storms from
time to time.
And we see this regularly
in the news.
A cold front will hit Florida,
and the prices will spike.
But the game allows people to
learn to not only solve
difficult analytic problems,
but to also do so in teams.
There's an extensive evaluation
process, students
write evaluations
of each other.
They're told how to
write evaluations.
There's even a little analytic
write up, where they have to
do the mathematics of
what they're doing.
But at the end of the day, it
really boils down to how well
they work together, and how will
the team leads can get
the most out of the talent
on their team.
JUAN SAGREDO: We have different
people that are in
communication with them.
We have by three graduate
serious who are in regular
communication on Skype,
basically letting them know
when they should submit
things, setting up on
what's going on.
We have a person that trouble
shoots things, and this all
goes on through Skype.
WILL HARREL: We have a few
different programs that we run
to analyze the results
and then fill
out part of the sheet.
And then we look through that,
make our own human judgments,
make some changes, and then
quickly fill out the sheet as
fast as we can.
And we just 10 minutes
to do that.
JACK CHING: We are usually
waiting on the industry
reports to be uploaded
by Professor Simao.
And that gives us a sense, but
it's a few years after the
fact, so we don't really know
how everyone else is doing
until at least a couple
of runs in the future.
HANNAH STEELE: We kind of had
trouble in the first run.
So we've been trying to get back
to profits since then.
WILL HARREL: We are constantly
watching how the
other teams are doing.
This is definitely a very
competitive game.
At the end of the game, the
team who earned the most
profit over the course
of all of the years
is the winning team.
WARREN POWELL: Round
of applause.
You guys did a great job.
You cannot win this
game by luck.
You have to do analysis.
It's careful planning and
execution that wins this game.
WILL HARREL: It was great to win
this, and I just feel like
all of our efforts have been
rewarded because we've been
working for, now, two or three
months on this game, and spent
some late nights.
And it's great just to
see that we were
able to come on top.